The prettiness of their wife is the same thing as, like,
how big is their truck? How fast is their car?
How big is their dick? It's like a pissing contest between other men.
So you know how insecure men have those really big trucks,
and you're like, okay,
I know what you got that truck for.
I know what we're compensating for here, sir.
The same thing applies in these traditional marriages for their wife.
Like, there is something super ugly and gross about the man,
and then they want the prettiest,
most trophies wife they can get.
Like Daniel Neilman in that article,
he talks about, the minute he saw her,
he was like, yes,
sign me up. She was, like,
the perfect height, the perfect blond hair,
the perfect whatever he had imagined in his head.
Like, you're not a person.
You are, like,
a object that they're fitting into their little life.
And so there is enormous, outrageous pressure to stay fit,
to stay beautiful.
I remember when we were having problems
and we went to marital counseling,
and we went to our pastor.
He literally told me, like,
one of my husband's issues was that I wasn't always dressed up.
I didn't, you know,
sometimes he came home from work and I wasn't so pretty.
And so, of course,
that's why he didn't want to do all the things I was asking him to do.
And I was like, well,
it's hard to feel pretty.
When all I do is sit home with fucking kids all day,
I'm driving myself crazy. I'm a human being,
not a fucking robot. You know,
like, anybody with true counseling
would have been able to really guide us in some way,
but this guy was like, well,
you know, it doesn't hurt to throw on a little lipstick and look pretty
sometimes. You don't have to be dressed like a playboy bunny,
but, you know,
you could, like,
use it up a bit. And I was like, okay,
so it's not just from your husband,
it's from, like,
the institutions that you guys participate in.
When you are in these traditional gender roles,
it's like, it is its own community. And, like,
you could hear them have pissing contest.
Like, I remember this one guy we went to church with,
his wife was a tennis pro.
So she was, like,
she worked at a tennis club,
and she was one of the professionals that helped teach it.
So she was, like,
super in shape. And he always, like,
about his wife, and, like,
I don't know, it was just.
And then among the girls, there's just so much cattiness
because you're trying to make sure you're still the prettiest.
And even though, like,
it's just. It's literally the ugliest of the ugly, ugly,
ugly, ugliest of humanity that comes out disguised as, oh,
but I just care about you.
Like, you should work out while you're pregnant,
because you Know,
the baby, the baby.
But there's no concern for the baby in other ways,
you know what I mean? Like,
it's not like a consistent cared.
You only care when it comes to how I look,
but like, when my feet are swollen and they need to be massaged,
oh, well,
blah, blah, blah.
Do you know what I mean? They only care about it
when it comes to how it's gonna affect how you look
and how you dress. For me postpartum,
I wore those fucking body wrap things that
our torture devices.
I don't think anybody should be putting their body through that
after fucking birth. But sure enough,
I was like, literally eight hours after giving birth,
strapping myself in one of those fucking things.
Way too tight. And then by the fourth baby,
I was like, this is my last opportunity to do anything.
And I used the hip one to make my hips smaller as well,
and it really did change my body.
And my hips feel funny. Uh,
it's just the pressure to be perfect is outrageous.
And that applies to everything,
especially. Especially,
especially your looks. I feel like that's why a lot of times they.
These men don't always resort to physical violence,
because they're not gonna bruise up the merchandise,
you know what I mean? They don't want a bruised banana.
They want you to be pretty.
They're just gonna hurt you in every other fucking way that they can.
I mean, some of them resort to violence, too,
but I'm just saying,
a lot of them are just make you feel like shit for who you are,
even if you know. So, yeah,
it's disgusting.
10 out of 10, don't recommend.